hello and welcome to math simplified in
this video we're gonna discuss about
five types of foods that are extremely
helpful in maintaining a healthy hair
your hair cells are the second fastest
growing cells in your body second only
to the intestinal cells but because hair
is not a vital organ or tissue your body
will never prioritize its nutritional
needs
so due to hairs expendable nature a
nutritional imbalance will often show up
first in the form of hair loss
your hair cells as well as all the cells
throughout your body need a balance of
proteins complex carbohydrates iron
vitamins and minerals to perform
function at the best
now there are a number of foods that
contain essential nutrients that will
maximize your hair's potential for
growing healthily and looking beautiful
and these right nutrients can help
promote hair growth especially if you're
experiencing hair loss due to poor
nutrition
now since hair follicles are among the
most metabolically active in the body
the hair growth is impacted by calorie
and protein malnutrition
as well as micronutrient deficiency so
in this video we will look at the five
types of best foods that contain these
essential nutrients
number one iron
iron deficiency is the world's most
common nutritional deficiency and is a
well-known cause of hair loss
foods rich in iron include veggies like
spinach legumes tofu chickpeas and
collard greens nuts like almonds cashews
and pistachios also contain good amount
of iron
non-vegetarian sources are good sources
of iron as they contain heme iron which
is more easily absorbed sources include
chicken breast lean meat fish beef liver
egg yolks etc
vegans and vegetarians are also at a
higher risk of iron deficiency as their
requirements for dietary iron are
considered to be 1.8 times higher than
for meat consumers
non-heme iron found in plants has a
lower bioavailability than heme iron
found in meat and fish
number two zinc
zinc is an essential mineral required by
hundreds of enzymes so it has an
important role in protein synthesis and
cell division
it is therefore a critical component for
development of a hair follicle
zinc rich foods include pumpkin seeds
sesame seeds watermelon seeds red meat
shellfish nuts like almonds and cashews
and vegetables like spinach and
mushrooms
number three biotin biotin also known as
vitamin b7 or vitamin h is an important
vitamin for hair follicle growth as it
is required for protein synthesis
it is also important for proper
development of your nails
symptoms of deficiency include skin
rashes conjunctivitis and hair fall
foods like eggs almonds cheese sweet
potatoes mushrooms spinach and legumes
are great sources of vitamin b7
biotin and zinc deficiencies are a very
common reason for diffuse hair loss so
if you are suffering from excessive hair
loss you should consider using zinc and
biotin supplementation i have included
links to some biotin and zinc
supplements in the description box below
number four is omega fatty acids
omega fatty acids especially omega-3 and
omega-6 fatty acid deficiency is also
very common and leads to symptoms like
graying of air and loss of scalp hair
since these fatty acids are very
important for hair follicle growth fatty
fish like salmon herring and mackerel
are excellent sources of omega-3 fatty
acids fatty fish is also a great source
of protein selenium vitamin d3 and v
vitamins nutrients that may help promote
strong hair and healthy hair
additionally you may consider
supplementation with omega fatty acids
too
number five is vitamin d data from
animal studies suggests that vitamin d
plays a critical role in hair follicle
growth cycle
vitamin d receptors are particularly
increased during the growth phase of the
hair follicle
deficiency of vitamin d is very common
and risk factors for vitamin d
deficiency include inadequate sun
exposure dark skin obesity gastric
bypass and fat malabs option
food sources of vitamin d include whole
milk cheese butter eggs nuts like
almonds fish like tuna sardines salmon
and mackerels
also make sure to give 10 to 15 minutes
of sun exposure every day as that is
essential to convert the vitamin d
present in your body into its active
form
so guys these were the five types of
nutrients that are essential for healthy
hair and also to prevent hair loss
in the end i would like to wish you all
a happy new year hope 2021 will be a
good one
i hope you liked the video if you did
make sure to subscribe to mad simplified
and follow us on instagram and facebook
thank you so much for watching